[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello and welcome to safety ridge on
sunday well it's been one of the most
testing weeks of boris johnson's
premiership with 41
conservative mps voting to say they have
no confidence in his leadership last
week we had the policy response but now
it feels like the real red meat is
coming around with brussels over brexit
with legislation to change the northern
ireland protocol coming tomorrow around
with the unions over strikes with
threats to change the law to allow
agency workers to cover striking staff
and a row in the courts over immigration
as the government battles to fly asylum
seekers to rwanda the prime minister
really is in fight mode well on the show
this morning we will have the northern
ireland secretary of brandon lewis for
the government we'll get the view from
the largest party in northern ireland
chin fame the party's president mary lou
mcdonald for labour we'll be talking to
the shadow chancellor rachel reeves and
with that first flight taking migrants
to rwanda due in the coming week we'll
be talking to the general secretary of
the pcs union mark sawatka which took
part in legal action against the policy
and the two british men face a death
sentence at the hands of russian forces
and occupied ukraine we'll be talking to
zina kotenko a young ukrainian woman who
fled this country during the war she's
close friends with a moroccan man being
held alongside the british pair
[Music]
hello we can start this morning with
northern ireland and news that's likely
to dominate the start of the week
because the government will tell us
tomorrow what it plans to do about the
protocol that's likely to involve
legislation to change or scrap parts of
the brexit agreement with the eu that's
created a trade border in the irish sea
while the stormont assembly remains
gridlocked with unionists demanding
changes before they'll take part we can
talk now to the northern ireland
secretary brandon lewis thank you very
much for being with us um i'm keen to
kind of deep dive into the northern
ireland situation in a moment but just
to start with ukraine um two british men
uh sentenced to death we're told after
being falsely accused of being
mercenaries in ukraine it's alongside a
moroccan national as well we're talking
to a friend of his
later on the programme
what is the government doing to try and
help these men
well i mean it's the fact that
the foreign secretary said it's
effectively a kind of sham trial really
but i think it it backs up what we've
all seen is this abhorrent uh process
that putin has followed in terms of an
unwarranted attack on ukraine in the
general way that putin's regime is
acting it's pretty despicable actually
we're working with the ukrainians these
are the people who are serving us in the
ukrainian armed forces they're protected
there from the geneva convention and i
know the foreign secretary is in close
contact with her counterparts in ukraine
to do everything we can to support the
individuals and support and work with
ukraine uh to get the right outcome to
this well this
disgraceful situation but it but it sums
up pretty much the whole way that putin
and his regime have acted over the last
few months
you know as you say it's a show trial
they've been falsely accused of being
mercenaries
is there anything we can actually do
well as i say it's difficult to go into
the details of any particular case and
obviously particularly that consent of
the individuals but the foreign
secretary the prime minister i know are
fully engaged on this uh working with
the ukrainians because they were serving
ukrainian armed forces and therefore
they are protected by the geneva
convention something that all
governments around the world
have respected for for decades now and
it's something that russia should
respect as well but as we've seen as i
say we've seen putin act in a pretty
abhorrent and illegal way consistently
over the last few months so we've got to
keep that pressure on and do everything
we can support not just these families
but actually everybody who's fighting
for uh for democracy actually in ukraine
i guess that's the issue there isn't you
said that putin is prepared to act
illegally given that you know is there
something we can do or not or not well
we've got to keep the pressure on we've
got to work through this in the proper
way and that's working with our partners
in ukraine because as i say they were
serving officers in the ukrainian armed
forces we will be continuing to do that
i know the foreign secretary as i say is
in close contact
with her counterparts there to do
everything we can as i say to support
not just those individuals but actually
the wider people of ukraine in the
battle that they're they're they're
dealing with uh putin's invasion we're
seeing some pretty um worrying reports
coming out of the fighting currently
happening in ukraine in the donbass
reports that they're running out of
ammunition heavy losses of course the
difficult phase of the war
do you think the tide is starting to
turn against ukraine
well but one of the things we've seen is
ukraine has consistently been have to
hold up uh its defense and to actually
put pressure on russia and slow rushes
advance and actually in some cases at
times push russia back a little bit
we're doing our bit to help obviously
we're leading that international
coalition and putting the support in
there again it's the great credit of the
defence sector and the prime minister
they were leading the way from the very
beginning getting support into ukraine
in northern ireland we're doing our bit
in the uh the end laws and star street
which is now coming into ukraine are
developed and produced in belfast and
i've been very proud to be able to go
and visit and see the team then people
in northern ireland are very proud of
what belfast is doing we've got to keep
up that support for the people more
weapons do you think well we're
continuing to send those defensive
lethal weapons support into ukraine and
i think there is an element of just that
general support of the western world and
we in the uk particularly leading on
that can give ukraine gives them the
confidence that the world is behind them
that they are in the right to defend a
sovereign democracy and we've got to
stand by that okay
now you of course are publishing
legislation tomorrow uh on the northern
ireland uh protocol this of course is
part of the brexit deal that this
government negotiated
is it going to contain notwithstanding
clauses now these clauses of course
would effectively override parts of the
withdrawal agreement well i'm not going
to go into the specifics of something
before we publish it to parliament but
you are right we're going to be
publishing legislation tomorrow i would
just say of course notwithstanding
clauses have a particular legal meaning
that give clarity to courts if they come
to interpret uh things down the line but
as i say what we're looking to do is fix
the problems we're seeing with the
protocol it's around how the protocol
has been implemented the lack of
flexibility we've seen from the eu over
the last year and a half of trying to
negotiate with them where they've not
really moved at all and in fact at the
moment what the eu are proposing will
send us backwards from where we are
today that isn't sustainable and every
political party in northern ireland
wants to see changes to the protocol we
want to fix it so it works for the
people of northern ireland and respects
all aspects of the belfast good friday
agreement which at the moment isn't
happening um
so
on the north withstanding clauses you
say that they proved provide clarity to
the courts effectively by overriding or
changing parts of the original agreement
what we're going to set out tomorrow is
a piece of legislation that will rectify
the issues that are there in the
protocol we've always said there has to
be an agreement between us and the eu
we've got to respect the question the
question is whether will it contain
these notwithstanding as i said i'm not
going to detail something before we
publish it department that's the right
thing to do we'll publish to parliament
the bill tomorrow what the bill will do
is restore all aspects of the belfast
good friday agreement there's three
strengths
a year ago a court in northern ireland
high court found that the protocol does
abide by the good friday agreement so
i'm not really sure that they are no
that's no let's be close with him i'm
sorry that's wrong what the court found
a year ago is that it doesn't override
certain aspects of the belfast good
friday agreement in one part what isn't
correct though is the belfast good
friday group has three strands both
north-south which at the moment is under
pressure and isn't working the north
south ministerial councils do not happen
at the moment that is not functioning
east west we know there are issues great
britain to north london over 200
businesses have stopped supplying
northern ireland and their certain
products we can't move to northern
ireland despite them being for
consumptional use within the united
kingdom single markets that isn't
working as strand one the fundamental
part of that is the institution of
stormont that is not functioning at the
moment there is no executive working so
all three strands are either broken or
under pressure that's the very thing
that the protocol was setting out to
protect it's not doing it so it's right
that we actually repair that okay now
the last time you tried to unilaterally
change the brexit deal to help trade in
northern ireland that's in september
2020
you acknowledged that that would break
the law in your words in a specific and
limited way
will the legislation tomorrow break the
law so couple things so three things
actually first of all the legislation
will outline tomorrow is within the law
what we're going to do is lawful and it
is correct but just two other really
important points when we set that out
when i set that out in late 2020 the
point we were making was we were giving
primacy to the belfast good friday
agreement it was about protecting that
over and above what was at that point
and incomplete withdrawal grim but i
would also say we of course took
unilateral action in the spring of last
year when we extended the grace periods
and those extensions are still in place
something you wouldn't agree at the time
but has recognized was actually
important you say you said that this is
acting within the law
how can we be so sure that it isn't
going to break the law are you going to
publish the legal advice that's based on
we're setting out the legal basis on
which we are um taking forward this
legislation i think when people see what
is the legal what is that when people
say what is the legal way when people
see the legislation tomorrow they will
see and we will be setting out our legal
position on this people will see that
what we are proposing resolves the key
issues within the protocol that don't
work so what is the legal basis on which
you're publishing this advice well we
have to actually outline what we're
doing in a context that is about
protecting the integrity of the belfast
good fighter group we've always said the
attorney general back in 2019 was very
clear belfast's good fine agreement
absolute has paramount importance to the
uk government it's the primacy it's the
original thing it's an international
agreement between us and the irish
government that we will always give
first priority to i'm just trying to
work out just to get onto the law on to
whether or not this is within the law
because for many people this is really
important you're very confidently
asserting uh that this is within the law
so
we publish the you committing to publish
publishing the advice on which that is
given but as i'm saying first of all
you'll see the latest people will see
the legislation smiles they'll see that
we're acting within the law and we as a
government will be outlining our legal
position and being very clear about why
this is absolutely within the law so sir
james edie is the first treasury council
effectively the government's top
independent legal advisor was he asked
whether this would break international
law i'm not going to get into the
internals of uh government advice that's
something we don't do but what i want
it's important though isn't it because
there is a lot of people who look at
this and they think this is going to
break international law and actually
rather than just saying it's not going
to
it the government's going to show it's
working
i'll go further than saying it's not
going to when people see the legislation
tomorrow and the government's legal
position they will see that this is
working within the law so walter james
edie asked whether it would break
international law the government lawyers
are very clear this we are working
within the law the attorney general will
be setting out the government's legal
position on that tomorrow in line with
the bill it's quite specific because you
don't even know he asked whether you
don't have to even ask my word for it
you can see the bill tomorrow and you
will see that what we're doing is within
the law okay and i just guess
some people look at this might think
look last time you you tried to sort of
change the protocol in order to change
the trade in northern ireland you at
least acknowledged that you would be
breaking the law no that didn't go so
let's be clear no no that that was
before the protocol was agreed in the
author
yeah there was no brexit deal there was
no protocol what we were setting out is
what we would need to do if there hadn't
been an agreement so we were taking an
insurance policy and we stood by our
word and once we secured that issue but
you know we didn't say that
you didn't you didn't take the action
and you're right um but you at least
acknowledged that it would be breaking
the law it feels like this time
you have effectively managed to to you
know that it's going to break the law
but you're just not being completely
honest with us oh no be very strange
look and say if as i say if you go back
to the point we were making at the time
we were being very clear that rather
than giving primacy to what was at that
point no brexit deal no trade agreement
and an incomplete withdrawal agreement
we were going to give primacy to the
belfast group friday agreement what we
are doing now is fixing the issues
within the protocol we we accept we've
always been clear there needs to be a
treaty agreement protocol between us and
the eu we need to respect the single
market protect north south trade as well
as east west and strand one institution
as a storm and giving privacy to the
belfast good friday agreement we are
going to set out legislation tomorrow
that will do that within the law in 2024
under the brexit deal politicians in
northern ireland will get to vote on
whether or not to keep the protocol it's
effectively the kind of exit clause and
it's northern ireland politicians who
get to make that decision
is there anything in the bill tomorrow
that could override that no in 2024
there is a consent mechanism and a vote
for the politician all the items and one
of these i think gets missed sometimes
is debate i guess all the political
parties in northern ireland at the
moment are clear the protocol in its
current state doesn't work yeah i i want
to come back on that a little bit
because it's much more complicated than
that oh yeah
that does feel you know a slight um
people often talk about this as well as
one political party and that's not
actually fair all the party leaders have
been very clear both with me in public
but there's they need to be checked but
you would accept that 54 of the 90 newly
elected mlas think that the protocol
effectively should keep going that they
disagree with the idea that it should be
scrapped you can also be changed you can
also point to the majority of uh from
the parties that are designated or
there's a larger proportion of those are
unionist mlas and they're all the
unionist party very clear they want the
protocol scrapped all together what
we're going to do is let's say set out
tomorrow we can restore the institutions
of northern ireland by fixing the
problems that are there should you not
ask if if the principle of consent is so
important you know the exit clause you
say won't be um
overruled
should you not ask the politicians in
northern ireland to get their approval
if you like for any unilateral changes
that you're willing to make when you
know that actually you know the majority
of people on who have been newly elected
54 of the 90 don't want to see it
scrapped well there's also
the last wide poll on this it was done
in northern ireland a few months ago now
actually set out 78 of the population in
northern ireland i felt the protocol
wasn't working and needed to be fixed so
we as uk government have a
responsibility to resolve this issue for
all people in northern ireland
businesses and all the whole community
of northern which we're going to do
obviously we're in continual contact
with all of the political parties i talk
to all the party leaders regularly and
we do as governments the dep giving you
an assurance that if there's
legislations go through that they will
they will join power sharing no that's a
matter for the dup i would expect to see
the dup when they see us resolving the
issues of the protocol
following what they said was their
position which is as they see the
protocol issues being resolved that they
would restore the institutions
but no that's a matter for the dup i
hope see them go back they should be
going back i have to say i would have
liked to have seen them being nominated
to speak in a different language
how long would you allow northern
ireland to go without an assembly before
calling another election well there's a
set piece of legislation now which gave
stability that came out the new decade
new approach agreement we passed that
earlier this year that means that the
assembly has 24 weeks for the parties to
work together to find a a program of
government that they can support and
i've written to all the parties to
encourage them to come together to the
very least be doing that work around a
program of government after 24 weeks
then we have to take a view about
whether there is a further election
uh now let's talk about immigration
shall we uh to send you want to send
asylum seekers to uh rwanda the
government won a battle in the high
court uh next week um last week sorry do
you expect that flight to take off on
tuesday yes
yes we do it's very good that we won
that
court case that's one stage of the
process and i think underlying this is
actually a a policy and a program that
huge credit to the home secretary and
the prime minister have taken this
forward because it's one that makes it
very clear to these abhorrent people who
run these modern slavery schemes and
this uh these treacherous uh runs across
the channel that this business model
will not work
if you're talking about if you're
talking about that it could be said that
this is actually incentive to bring
children with you over the seas isn't it
because then you won't get sent to
rwanda no it's a very clear message to
the and this is part of a wider package
you're absolutely right there is no
silver bullet to deal with the issues
around illegal immigration these are
criminals who will always be looking at
what is the next thing but it is right
we're clear to them that we're going to
break that business model what they're
doing will not work like putting aside
the kind of government line
are you personally comfortable with this
policy yes i am actually and i think it
is right but we're very clear to people
there are a number of legal routes to
which people can come to this country
and that's important for two reasons one
is we've got to make sure that when
people come here we can give them the
proper support to be part of our society
but people are coming illegally we've
got to make sure that these vile gangs
know that that will not work it's not
the right way to do it prince charles
has privately described the policy as
appalling and private comments but they
have of course appeared in the
newspapers are you comfortable with the
future king
openly talking about government policy
in this way well they're not just
private companies they're rumored
private commerce i think it's uh i don't
think it's appropriate to comment on
what somebody says they might have heard
without any context of it the reality is
this is a policy that is going to
deliver to ensure that modern slavery
and these people smugglers know that
their criminal methods will be broken
down and saying to people around the
world if you are a refugee if you're
asylum seeker if you're a legal migrant
coming to this country we want to give
you the support to properly help you be
part of the uk economy part of the uk
way of life which is what you want and
that's right but we've got to do that in
a proper legal managed way and people
are encouraging you to travel illegally
are wrong and we're going to break their
business model um we're facing a summer
of strikes the sunday telegraph
reporting that the government could
bring in agency staff in order to break
the strikes um grant shap saying you're
looking at says you're looking at
changing uh changing the law to allow
employers to effectively use agency
staff to break strikes to cover for
striking workers is that true
well we're looking at as grant said look
today actually we're looking at a whole
range of things i think it's right that
we do that i think is right that we are
looking at everything we can do to
support hard-working people are looking
often to get to work get children to
school get to hospital appointments not
being disrupted by strike action
particularly in a sector where i think
the median pay in that sector is almost
double what the average pay is for
citizens in the uk
so i think it is right that we are on
the side of working people and that
grant is rightly looking at all the
options would that not be undermining
you know the people's right to strike i
think it's supporting the general
public's right to get to work to get to
emergency appointments to get to school
to live their everyday life as i say we
all talk about an interview as i say i
think the median salary is about 46 000
as opposed to an average salary in the
uk about 26 000. so i think it is right
but we are looking to support people who
are looking to go out everyday lives in
a normal way and they have a right to do
so it's been a
pretty difficult week for the prime
minister i'm sure you'll uh you know
acknowledge uh 41 of conservative mps uh
voting to have no confidence him he's
he's announced his kind of policy blitz
if you like he's also hinted very
strongly at the prospect of tax cuts
he's described the current tax
burden as an aberration in tuesday's
cabinet he said we have the scope by
delivering tax cuts to deliver growth so
what kind of tax cuts can we expect well
actually i think what this week
highlights is the prime minister is
getting on with the job you know they're
we're continuing to work to deliver for
people
in terms of tax cuts i'm a conservative
and i believe in a low tax economy i
think lower taxes is pretty unhappy with
your current situation well i think what
we've we've always got
but we're also making sure that as of
next month seventy percent of the
population are going to have a tax
reduction through the increase in the
national threshold we're making sure
what but
we're making sure the businesses who are
making huge profits incentivized to use
that money to go into investment for the
future we've got to make sure that we're
using tax in a way that isn't fiscally
sensible because we have had an
exorbitant period through kovi where we
have supported the public that costs
money the war in ukraine that cost money
we've got to be sensible about this but
doing that in a way that creates a
foundation where we can bring in more
tattoos so what difference would you
like it's a good thing for the united
kingdom
i'm not going to prejudge the chance
that's all no no no no no
one else
i've been on your show enough over the
years you know i'm never going to
prejudge the difference
complicated fiscal decisions the
chancellor has to make but even before
this week the chancellor and the prime
minister were clear that as soon as the
fiscal situation allows we've got to be
very sensible about that we're managing
public money after all we want to see
tax cuts and the chance of one supreme
tax cuts in some poor people have more
money in their pocket to spend how they
know they can spend their best i just
want to end by a quote from somebody
that i spoke to on wednesday uh when we
on the wednesday night program and we we
basically talked to a focus panel if you
like of conservative voters this is a
guy called john comfort
he's a pensioner he's someone who
isolated at home during the pandemic he
wasn't able to go to the funeral of
loved ones
and he told me this he said i voted
conservative all my life
and i wouldn't even think about not
voting conservative but i cannot vote
for boris johnson i just won't vote at
all which at my age having voted ever
since i was 18 would actually disturb me
i mean this is a man who is effectively
desperate to vote conservative he can't
bring himself to vote for anyone else
he's always voted for conservative
parties since he was 18. he says he
cannot do it anymore
i mean it must be
you know for concerned mps like you
listening to that
it must be pretty upsetting well i think
it's a very clear reminder of the work
we've got to between now and the next
generation indeed depending on where he
lives in the potentially local elections
next year to convince people like john
yeah okay so he's probably mayor will
have district elections even next year
our work and the focus for us has to be
on working to ensure we can earn his
vote at the next election because it's
important for prime minister that he
can't be yeah and actually yeah and i
would and i would like to think that as
he'll see over the next year or so as a
prime minister he's focused on
delivering for people in the united
kingdom giving a better life for people
in the future that he is the right man
to lead us into that next generation i
think he is and i hope the people like
john are the sort of people will be able
to convince to continue to vote for them
all breaking even tomorrow sorry no more
law breaking even tomorrow we're going
to be working within the law but we are
importantly going to fix a problem that
has been detrimental to the lives of
people in north london we have a duty to
do that and it's right that we do it
okay thank you very much lewis uh there
well labour has set out a plan for what
it calls a stronger and more secure
economy the party says it would cut
business rates increase the digital
services tax and insulate more homes but
the opposition remains under pressure to
explain its position on the looming
strikes or we can speak now to the
shadow chancellor rachel reeves before
we get on to the strikes and some of the
labour policy i just want to come off
the back of the interview we've just had
to talk about northern ireland brandon
lewis there saying that the legislation
published tomorrow will not break the
law do you believe him
well we haven't seen the legislation yet
but it does look like the government
plan to break international law now this
government seemed to be developing a
record for law breaking and it's not one
that the labour party can support but we
help bring in the good friday agreement
we are deeply passionately committed to
it we want the northern ireland protocol
to work but we know
to to get it to work we have to
negotiate and work with our european
partners now kia stammer was in belfast
and dublin last week talking to leaders
talking to businesses showing the
leadership that frankly is lacking from
the prime minister today
so it's um what exactly uh do you want
to happen then with the northern ireland
protocol
there's some very practical things
sophie that could happen pretty much
straight away the first would be to get
a bespoke veterinary agreement between
the eu and the uk to help speed speed up
the movement of goods and services not
just between northern ireland and uh the
rest of of britain but also between uh
the uk and um
and the rest of the european uh union
new zealand has got a veterinary
agreement with the eu it can't be on
beyond the wit of the eu and the uk to
negotiate one of those so you don't have
this huge bureaucracy and delays at the
border which are causing so many many
problems particularly in northern
ireland but also at dover as well so
there are practical things like that
that require statecraft they require a
building of trust and those are the
things that boris johnson has not been
able to do and those skills and those
abilities i believe that stammer has
those in spades
uh right let's talk about the strikes
then it's something that many of our
viewers are going to be really concerned
about in the weeks and months ahead
um according to the sunday telegram
today the government's reportedly ready
to remove a legal restriction that was
introduced under tony blair that would
prevent employers hiring agency workers
to cover striking staff would you back
the use of agency workers
it just doesn't make any sense the way
to resolve this is to get people around
the table but the idea that you can
replace a skilled train signaler with an
agency worker would you feel safe going
on a train knowing that it was an agency
worker rather than a properly skilled
and trained up trained signaler i know
that i wouldn't so instead of this uh
fanning the flames and increasing
tensions the government needs to act
like firefighters rather than arsonists
and try and get some resolution to this
because the people that will pay the
price if these strikes go ahead are
ordinary working people who want to go
out to work people who need to get to
doctors appointment and
have operations in hospitals businesses
who are after everything they've gone
through need their workers in the office
but also people who work in the train
industry will lose pay if they're not
going to work so nobody wants these
strikes to happen the government though
are not an observer in all of this
they're an actor and they need to be
getting people around the table and
resolving these disputes instead of
fanning the flames of the fire um this
week your shadow house secretary west
streeting said put it this way
if i was a member of the rmt and my job
was at risk like this then i would be
voting to go on strike would you be
voting to go on strike
well they've already um they've already
had those those those votes those
decisions made but it's not too late to
avert the strikes and you know what i'm
gonna come in i'm sorry i'm sorry rachel
i'm sorry i'm gonna have to come in on
that because that really wasn't a
straight answer at all would you be
voting to go on strike if you were an mt
worker
well look i want to be the chancellor of
the exchequer sophie that is the job
that i aspire to do and if i was
chancellor of the exchequer today i
would be doing everything within my
power to avert these strikes that's what
people want from a government a
government that is on the side of
ordinary working people trying to uh to
resolve problems rather than to fan the
flames and that's the job that i want to
do i want to be the chancellor of this
great country and if i was chancellor i
would be doing everything i can to avoid
the huge disruption that will come from
strike actions and that's what i want to
see from this prime minister and this
chancellor i spoke to the rmt general
secretary lynch on the show a little
while ago and he said i've seen no
response from the labour front bench
that says we support the workers and
their struggles if we just get this
bland democratic party sitting in the
center of politics taking their
instructions off the daily mail not
getting behind worker struggles you have
to ask yourself why do they actually
call themselves the labour party
do you think he has got a point that
you're being a bit
well look the labour party are the party
of working people the clue is in the
name and i'm incredibly proud of the
relationship between the labour party
and our trade unions and unlike the um
the rail unions we don't want to see
agency workers uh uh coming in who are
not qualified to do jobs they're putting
public uh safety at uh at risk but look
we also want to do everything we can to
avert these flights and i know that the
people who work in the train industry
don't want these strikes to happen
either they want a government that's on
their side that tries to resolve these
disputes and as i say sophie if i was in
government today that would be my number
one priority
okay now today you're criticizing the
conservative party for what you're
calling it's sticking plaster approach
to deep economic policies um but just to
talk about labor because i've been
asking labor politicians you know for
some weeks now you know what's the big
transformative idea the vision if you
like from the labour party
analyst dodd says it's to buy make and
sell more in the country
mcfadden told me it's about two hundred
thousand children living in areas with
no outstanding schools lisa nandy said
good clean jobs kierstama talked about a
windfall tax to reduce energy bills
i just can't help thinking you know it's
a reason that everyone seems to give a
different answer to this question
because there isn't a single big
transformative policy from the labour
party
the great thing about those answers
sophia is it shows that labour party is
buzzing with ideas and indeed labour is
winning the battle of ideas in politics
today you see that with the u-turn from
the government on the windfall tax and i
remember speaking on your program back
in january when i first started calling
for a win for tax and government
ministers said oh we can't do that
because the energy companies are
struggling and it would stop investment
and five months later the government
bowed to the inevitable introduced that
windfall tax and you know if the
tourists have run out of ideas and they
clearly have then we've got plenty more
of them as annalisa has said our plans
to buy make and sell more in britain as
lisa says our plans to ensure that every
part of the country has jobs that pay a
decent wage where the government matches
the ambition that people have for their
families and their communities so labour
party are buzzing with ideas under kiers
leadership we are winning uh the votes
of people who turned away from labour at
the last couple of uh elections and will
continue to set out
more of those ideas as i am to doing
today on labour's plans for a stronger
and more secure economy because as well
as that wound for tax which is much
needed to tackle the cost of living
crisis right now we do need more than a
sticking plaster approach we need to be
boosting our energy security our supply
chain security security for businesses
because only by doing those things will
we boost the economic security of
families and family finances right
across the country
now i know you are obviously a
kierstalmer loyalist but ever since of
course he said that he would resign if
durham police found against him there's
been lots of leadership speculation it
feels like every time that we're
streeting or lisa and nandy open their
mouths people see it as a leadership
pitch and i was just thinking before
this interview i'm not sure if anyone's
actually asked you the question and
would you fancy a run at the leadership
at some point if the opportunity were to
arise
but there's not the opportunity is not
there you know kier is the leader of the
labour party i don't know although he
said quite rightly that if he is fined
well i said a moment ago you know i want
to be chancellor of the extract the only
thing i don't like about my job title
today is the shadow at the beginning of
it i want to be the child
i'm absolutely
i'm absolutely not saying first green
chance like that is what i want to do
i'm absolutely not saying that you're
not a kid i'm a loyalist and that's why
i sort of introduced a question with
that proviso but that is that is
definitely not a ruling out is it
but there's just there's no there's
nothing to there's nothing to see here
you know there's no leadership contest
but at the point about kia saying that
he would resign if he was fined was to
show the contrast really between
kiyosama a man of honesty integrity of
decency he wants to restore those
values of trust and decency to politics
and public life compared to a rule
breaking a prime minister who has no
respect for the ministerial code uh for
the conduct of of politics and that's
why i'm so proud to uh to stand here as
a member of kiyostama's shadow cabinet
and why i'm so desperate to get rid of
this prime minister with a bluster and
the failure to rise to the challenges of
the country and at the same time is is
lying and cheating uh that is is uh is
so discrediting this government and our
country
okay rachel reeves uh thank you very
much indeed rachel ruth says hello
chancellor thank you
well we can turn back to northern
ireland now as we expect the government
to tell us what it wants to change about
the protocol that has created this trade
border in the rsc xinfane recently made
history by winning the most votes and
seats in the election but it's been
unable to take its place in the assembly
as the dep refuses to take part until
the protocol is reformed
or scrapped or we can go live to dublin
now we can speak to you at the chinfane
president mary lou mcdonald
now as we just heard from branson lewis
the uk government's going to be
publishing legislation tomorrow that we
believe could override parts or change
parts of the protocol in northern
ireland you told my colleague beth rigby
that the blizzard of paper is
problematic so do you have sympathy with
the view that the northern ireland
protocol does need to be changed
no i do not and i have even less
sympathy with a tory government that
brags now for such a long time that it
intends to breach international law
we're we're just about i think 40 days
out now from that election in in the
north
and we don't have institutions of
government it's it's utterly disgraceful
that we're in this place and bear in
mind a majority a significant majority
of people return to the assembly in the
north of ireland support the protocol
the protocol is working the protocol is
the mechanism that gives the north
uniquely unfettered access to the
european market and that is why we see
in the north of ireland in contrast with
britain with the exception of the the
city of london the the economy is strong
the economy is growing and what the tory
government is proposing to do in
breaching international uh law is to
create huge huge damage to the northern
economy to the irish economy
they propose to breach international law
and they are on an agenda of undermining
attacking and damaging the good friday
agreement
you uh say that a couple of things to
unpick there you say that the
tory government the uk government
is going to breach international law now
brandon lewis told me on the program he
assured me several times that the
changes would not
break international law
what evidence do you have that it will
well can i can i what can i say to you
that brandon lewis is talking through
his hat and not for the first time
brandon lewis should know the tory
government should know that where there
are issues to be resolved with the
protocol
issues of smoothing out its application
there are mechanisms through which that
can happen there is a willingness there
is a willingness to engage by the
european commission but the british
government has refused to engage
has not been constructive has sought a
destructive path and is now proposing to
introduce legislation that will
undoubtedly breach international law and
by the way against the expressed
democratic wishes of people in the north
of ireland who went to the polls and who
made their democratic decision and have
returned a majority of members that
support the protocol all of the business
organizations across the north of
ireland will tell you that yes there are
issues that need to be resolved get that
done get that done by way of negotiation
but they will also tell you that the
protocol is necessary that the protocol
is working that the protocol can work
better because all of them be very very
clear no the jobs prosperity and healthy
economic growth rely on access to the
european market nobody wants to
jeopardize and forego that and it's
astonishing
that the british government brags
consistently that they will
change as they push it or ditch elements
of the protocol breach international law
bring themselves into a collision with
europe at a time when we have your uh
war in europe cause untold economic
damage to the north of ireland and why
why well because there is an internal
leadership problem within the tory party
it is disgraceful to use the north of
ireland to use ireland as a bargaining
chip
in their ongoing collision with europe
all designed to boost the ego at the
leadership ambitions of either boris
johnson or one of his would-be
successors it's dishonorable stuff
by any measure extraordinary stuff that
the british parliament it seems now is
set to have tables before it legislation
specifically designed to breach an
international agreement that that very
parliament ratified
and an agreement that not so long ago
the current occupant of number 10
downing street just described as oven
ready and let me emphasize again
uh in the democratic test on these
matters at the people of the north have
spoken
a majority of mlas elected to the
assembly support the protocol and when
there is a vote in 2024 assuming that
the assembly
is up and running and even if it's not a
majority of those mlas will vote to
continue and support that protocol
and in 2024 uh of course according to
the brexit deal uh politicians in
northern ireland specifically get to
decide whether or not they want to keep
the protocol in place it's effectively
like an exit clause that was worked into
the original deal
i just wonder how important you think it
is that those politicians in northern
ireland get to make the final decision
on the protocol because you know there
is
rumors uh that the
uh
the
bills tomorrow the legislation
introduced tomorrow could effectively
override that consent vote
well let me say this uh just remember
that when when brexit happened and the
vote was taken people in the north voted
to remain just just remember that
and people on on a cross-community basis
from from all walks of life voted to
remain and i would wager if there was a
vote on the brexit question again next
week or next month that by an even
greater margin people in the north of
ireland would vote uh to remain so
brexit never had the democratic consent
or imprimatur of the people of the north
and therefore any idea that the tory
government would try to rob the elected
representatives of the north of ireland
of their rightful decision
on this matter would be absolutely
outrageous and and would mean that not
alone is the tory government
waging an onslaught against the protocol
prepared to breach international law and
walk away from its international
obligations but that in fact it is
damaging undermining power sharing in
the north of ireland and it would be
further and very very
very very dangerous evidence of a tory
attack on the good friday agreement uh
itself a very very dangerous suggestion
i mean i i should say at this point
obviously that brandon lewis says that
part of the reason they want to do this
is to effectively restore all elements
of the good friday agreement as the uh
assemblies
listen sophie sophie
sophia that just needs to be scotched
i mean that that's just that's frankly
beyond disingenuous uh the the tory
government consistently
abuses language uh in in a way that is
mesmerizing they say they want to
protect the good friday agreement when
they take the very actions that
undermine and that could potentially
destroy the good friday agreement that's
the reality and they are doing this in
plain sight they're colluding with the
section of political unionism to keep
the executive down in belfast to ensure
that the north-south element of the good
friday agreement is now
not operating to wage an attack on the
protocol the protocol to guarantee
access to the european market but
crucially to ensure no hardening of the
border on on ireland they have acted
unilaterally
in terms of legislation to deal with
victims and survivors of the conflict
they threaten still to withdraw from the
european convention and human rights all
of the building blocks in other words
upon which the good friday agreement has
been carefully constructed by all of us
are now being openly attacked and
undermined by the tory government and i
think it is so important that everybody
in political life quite irrespective of
their view be they conservative
be they labor wherever we fall on the
political spectrum we have a joint
vested interest in ensuring that the
good friday agreement is protected and
the tories need to be called out on this
not just by politics but by every sector
across civic society and ultimately by
by the people and i have whereas i have
no confidence i have to tell you in
boris johnson or his government i have
every confidence in decent people across
britain to realize that jeopardizing the
good friday event and the peace that all
of us
have built is totally unacceptable
it's pretty clear how
strong you feel about this and would you
like to see the united states
potentially getting involved
the united states is involved the united
states is involved because they know as
surely as we know that what is at play
here is a very very deliberate set of
actions that undermine the good friday
agreement and everybody from from the
white house from president biden across
american politics on a bipartisan basis
and you know as well as i do there are
few issues that unite political opinion
in the united states but this is one of
them
all of us have skin in this game
everybody knows that to protect the good
friday agreement if there is an absolute
imperative on boris johnson and his
government to act in good faith to act
constructively to engage to respect
the rule of law and to understand that
ireland will not be will not be let me
repeat the collateral damage in the
games and gamesmanship at play currently
within the tory party and i have to tell
you i believe that not alone
do we have international diplomatic and
political opinion on the side of ireland
on this question i think any person with
an ounce of common sense and an ounce of
decency and the people of britain have
that in abundance know that all of us
have to get on with our lives we're
living through a cost of living crisis
it's going to get really hard in the
autumn and the winter all of us know
that we need a level of stability
maturity and competence and all of us
know
that our relationships with each other
are fundamentally rooted in the good
friday agreement and the protection of
that we are at time but i do want to
talk to you just very finally uh about
the prospect of a border pole uh
essentially a referendum on a united
island you've said previously that you
think that will take place within the
next 10 years and you said that you want
to see an indication from the british
government as to how they might measure
when they would regard it to be
appropriate obviously in scotland it was
when the s p had it in their manifesto
they then went on to
win uh the most seats uh in the election
and went on to enact that referendum so
at what trigger point would you like to
see
a border pole being called in ireland
in northern ireland sorry well my
priority at
at this point well there will have to be
two referendums in fact sophie in the
north and in the south in both
jurisdictions
at this point the big priority for me
and for us is that preparation for such
a referendum is underway we have to have
a very wide all of society conversation
and that has to include unionism those
for who will campaign against
reunification those for whom as we move
into united island this would not be
their first preference but we need we
need to hear all of those voices and so
i have urged dublin to begin the
preparation now i think there is uh
nothing to be gained by burying our
heads in the sand i mean the recent
election in the north is just the latest
demonstration of of how profound the
change is uh across ireland and of
course the government at westminster the
the british government i think have to
indicate what their view is how how they
view the matter of at the tipping point
when the referendums will be held but
either either or whatever the answer
might be to that particular question be
in no doubt the change a positive change
exciting change progressive change is
underway in ireland that's good news for
all of us and this island it's good news
also for britain and because uh a part
of the whole project of building a new
island is building renewing
consolidating that relationship that we
have with our nearest neighbor
okay uh thank you very much for coming
on the uh program uh this morning very
strong views given
yourself of course and thank you very
much
now the public and commercial services
union took the unprecedented step of
taking part in legal action against the
government over its policy to remove
asylum seekers to rwanda and it's of
course the job of civil servants to
implement the policy putting them on a
collision course with the government
we can talk now to the pcs union general
secretary at mark sawatka who joins us
now from wales i believe um good to see
you on the programme and before we get
to the rwanda case i just want to talk
to you about the story in the sunday
telegraph today grant chaps giving an
interview where he says agency workers
could be brought in to effectively break
strikes to cover uh the jobs of striking
workers that would be changing at the
law to remove that restriction what's
your reaction
well that would be an outrageous act if
the government go down that road we've
already got the most restrictive
anti-union legislation in the whole of
western europe it's already incredibly
difficult for unions and workers to
withdraw their labor there are so many
legal loopholes to fly through
and if you think about what grand chaps
is trying to do with that legislation is
to make industrial action ineffective
now i believe it's a basic human right
to be able to withdraw your labor you
only do it as a last resort and any
attempts to bring people in to undermine
disputes will not resolve the problems
at the end of the day a dispute happens
because there's disagreement between the
employer and the workforce that
disagreement is not going to be resolved
if people can be brought in to undermine
disputes it will lead to bitterness it
will lead to division and it will lead
to these problems getting worse so what
grandchat should really be doing is
trying to resolve the dispute to ensure
that our rail workers frontline public
sector workers have decent paying
conditions they're not threatened with
cutting their cost of living standards
and he should try to resolve the dispute
not pour petrol on the flames and make
matters worse
you know you say that you know strikes
are the last resort for workers and i
just wonder if you know the government
might feel that this kind of changed the
law is a last resort for itself too and
you know we've heard from the rnt saying
that they're going to call they're going
to call
an unknown number of strikes that could
go on for an unknown number of days or
weeks over the summer it could
potentially have ruled out
you know lead to a situation where the
lights go off and do you worry that the
unions might actually overplay their
hand a little bit here and that's why we
could be seen as pushback from the
government
no i think my own view is probably the
unions have underplayed their hand now
over far too many years you know we've
seen right across trade unions in the
public and private sector terms and
conditions eroded in the civil service
for example we've seen 11 consecutive
years of real terms pay cuts
and the fact that it's so difficult now
to organize lawful industrial action
means all the cards are stacked in the
favor of the government or unscrupulous
employers as we've recently seen with
piano ferries who just similarly
dismissed 800 workers and brought people
in at deplorably low levels of pay so
the point of industrial action is that
it gives workers collectively the chance
to stand together to try and get a
better deal
and i think that we have a long and
proud history of the right to strike of
the right of people to defend themselves
as a last resort and what i would hope
that your viewers would understand
sophie is when people go on strike they
lose pay it's the last thing that they
want to do
but if a company is insisting on cutting
your pay cutting your pension cutting
your job for example and they will not
listen to reason it's the last thing you
can do and of course if you're going to
withdraw your labor the point of doing
that is to have an effect to try to get
people back around the negotiating table
so this is a wrong move on top of
already incredibly restrictive
legislation and it will make matters
worse not resolve the problems that we
want to see resolved
we spoke to rachel reeves a little
earlier on the programme she refused to
go as far as we're streeting who said
that if he was a member of the rmt he'd
be voting for
strike action and i spoke to mick lynch
on the program a couple of weeks ago and
he said that he effectively thought that
the labour party weren't showing there
on the side of workers he asked the
question what's the point
of the labour party
do you agree with mick lynch do you
think that their response has been a bit
too bland
well i would certainly like to see a lot
stronger support from the labour party
and of course many in the labour party
have been quite supportive you know
whether that's john mcdonnell or whether
that's lisa and andy in recent weeks
but what the labour party are going to
have to do is come up with a position
because the way things are going we're
going to see more industrial action as
the year goes on because people are
facing such a catastrophic cut in their
living standards or in my case
representing people who have been told
one in five ninety one thousand of them
face losing their jobs they're being
told they're getting a two percent pay
rise when inflation is nine to eleven
percent depending on what index you use
we saw the general secretary of unison
the other day say that she was
considering balloting unison's 1.1
million members so the labour party will
have to decide whose side they are on
and given it was founded by the trade
unions and they are there to speak up
for working men and women i would hope
that we would see kia stammer and his
team fundamentally come out on the side
of nurses doctors job center workers
rail workers and education workers
that's what we want is a political voice
in parliament okay stands with the
people who are having to take this
difficult stand now of course the pcs
union took the unusual action uh last
week of trying to stop the government's
plan to send asylum seekers to rwanda
you took court action which you lost the
judge the judge sorry found in favor
of the government to allow that flight
to rwanda to
go ahead
um are you going to be appealing the
decision and do you think that or do you
know except that this flight is going to
go ahead on tuesday
no we're appealing the decision we're in
the high court tomorrow appealing the
decision
and as you say this is an unprecedented
step sophie but but let me explain why
we're doing it
we have to test the legality of these
proposals but also we need to debate
about the morality and lack of humanity
that the government is demonstrating
when people are fleeing from iraq or
iran or syria or yemen and they come to
this country they are fleeing death
torture and persecution
we should welcome people to this country
and treat them civilly and assess their
cases when they are here
the fact that people are taking to small
boat crossings in the channel shows how
desperate they are and our members civil
servants 80 of whom we represent in the
border force
don't come to work to be asked to turn
those boats back mid-channel which is
what pretty propel demanded that they
did two months ago and i remind viewers
we went to court then we lost two
injunctions but we would have won the
case which is why the home office
withdrew its policy and let's remember
what pretty patel wanted pcs members to
do was to turn dinghies back mid-channel
at risk of death that was stopped by a
legal process and that's why we're
taking legal action now and we hope we
win tomorrow in the court of appeal to
stop the flight
but of course the legality of these
proposals will only be tested out at the
full court sharing in july and we're
absolutely confident that in july in
line with what the unhcr said very
graphically in court we believe these
proposals will be found to be unlawful
now i just i i appreciate the sort of
strength of feeling that many will feel
many of our viewers as well about this
uh policy
i just want to read a part of the civil
service code
it says you must not frustrate the
implementation of policies once
decisions are taken
you must serve the government whatever
its political persuasion to the best of
your ability in a way which maintains
political impartiality no matter what
your own political beliefs are
in seeking an injunction to try and stop
this flight you know you're effectively
trying to change and frustrate the
implementation of policy
many would argue that is breaching the
code
well many may argue that of course i
think the first part i would make is
when that civil service code was written
it was based on two fundamental premises
firstly that anything you were asked to
do as a civil servant was lawful
we believe that this is not lawful and
the court has yet to determine that's
the case
but secondly it presupposes that the
government of the day itself abides by
the rule of law and acts within the rule
of law we know this government has shown
demonstrably he has not done that and
what we saw if we can just for a minute
look at the partygate proposals is when
it came down to it it's civil servants
who were fined it's civil servants who
are now facing disciplinary action while
the prime minister seems to get away
scot-free so given the government's
disregard for the rule of law
to be fair the courts have found in
favor of the government or you know the
last week
well well they they've not found these
proposals legal what what happened last
week was an injunction was refused the
legality of the proposals will not be
determined until july and sophie the
question i would respectfully ask is
imagine if you're a civil servant now in
the home office who goes to work because
you want to see a humane immigration
system where people are treated fairly
and we comply with our international
obligations imagine if you're told to do
something on tuesday that in july is
subsequently found to be illegal that
would be an appalling situation and if
pretty patel had any respect
not just for the desperate people who
come to this country but for the workers
she employs she would not ask a single
one of them to be part of any
deportation of any asylum seeker until
at least these cases are heard in court
for the full legality judgment
will be in july
just finally uh quickly um you rejoined
the labour party in 2016 to support
jeremy corbyn in transforming the party
are you still a member under kyoustama
yes i am
okay uh thank you very much uh indeed
mark's marx walk there
thank you
to ukraine now and two british men and a
moroccan had been sentenced to death in
the donetsk region of ukraine that's
under occupation by russia and its proxy
forces the prime minister says the
government must do everything possible
to secure the release of the two british
men aiden aslan and sean pinner and the
moroccan man who was a 21 year old
ibrahim sadhu surrendered in maripol in
april that of course was when he was
captured along with the two
uh brits by russian forces
now his friend zinatenko is a 22 year
old ukrainian woman she came here to the
uk through the sponsorship scheme she's
now living with her mum at a host family
near sheffield she joins us now thank
you so much for being with us it must be
such a difficult time for you so we do
appreciate you speaking to us um
just talk to us about ibrahim he's a 21
year old moroccan he moved to keeve to
study you met him in a nightclub i think
yeah yep i met him and keep my club here
41.
on the
floor thankful to our
common friends
from america ticonder tillanton and jake
um
i met him and
just from the start we
had a nice conversation
he opened his heart to me and as well i
to him
very open-minded person
and very kind and
just from the start he also mentioned
that he is aimed to join our army
ukrainian army and he already tried
several times to join that but
unfortunately
he needed to gain some weight
so
he
even cheated he was drinking water
before uh the community
now
to gain some weight and
yeah so they can
accept him and he can join our army so
he managed to
go to marines
to protect us
it was yeah before the full-scale
invasion started
what a story and i have to say like from
the images of him he does look like
quite a slight guy like he's obviously
quite young but he does look like quite
a slight guy that so i can imagine a
drinking water story it does does yeah
um
it's important of course to talk about
how he joined the ukrainian army because
it obviously goes against the sham trial
the claims that are in russia that he
was mercenary he was clearly
fighting on behalf of ukraine along with
the two british men as well
just explain how did he end up fighting
in mario paul how does someone go from a
nightclub and cave to the the fight in
mario paul
well um
in kiev nightclub especially if we are
talking about k-41 knight club
um
that's place that's a place
for all of the people
that's lgbtqs plus friendly nightclub
and there's no progesterone
no discrimination so the place like we
want ukraine to be and to others to see
ukraine like this
so this club is more about the community
we had a lot of our national stars
dancing in there even the advice of
president is dancing there
let's jump so and he mentions
it on instagram even
in his profile that he's a raver
yes it's more about community all of the
people
go to this nightclub
it's about
who you are not
which music do you prefer
and when did you last
when did you last hear from ibrahim
it
was
in a early it was in the early march
and what was happening at the time
yeah he was
posting some photos from his
drama he was put since a photo from army
and
i was just asking him what is that
because it looks so hilarious
so he was explaining me how he was
living in there
and
yeah
he usually say everything is all right
everything is okay
uh do not worry about me and that's
what he continues to say right now if
you
managed to
see the last video raheem
he recorded for his mother and father
for his family and
even now he is assuring his mom mom
don't worry about me and he's looking at
the camera and he's smiling that's the
person who
he is
exactly
his
portrait
very cheerful person
it's quite moving thinking if you know
the 21 year old you know who's got this
death sentence trying to reassure his
mum that you know everything will be
okay and i'm sure how concerned you and
his family must be
what would you
what would your message be to you know
the uk government to the moroccan
government what do you want to see
happen
please care about people who care about
democracy because people
and our actions of common people our
lives that's the key to the bright
future that's the key to wealthy future
because when the government only think
about
money or
some profits
that's not the way people should treat
it
not the way
because people are the voice people are
the face of the government
so now the face of the government is
sitting in the prison
in an eligible court
so please save your fates
i just want to talk about you for a
minute as well uh you're obviously a
young woman and you're from ukraine from
kiev
you're now in sheffield
your life has obviously been completely
upended and i'm sure like every
ukrainian
you know you have your own trauma and
your own stories um
tell us a bit about your story how did
you escape from ukraine have you left
anyone behind how are you
i feel terrible
i i cry a lot i've never cried so much
sometimes i feel like around the grand i
was
sinning no more tears left to cry
i except kiev
after um
[Music]
after
a week
when the full-scale invasion started i
didn't believe that it would last for a
long time
but
unfortunately that's our reality it
lasts for long i do not really think it
will
um
it will end in another half a year a
year maybe
so yeah i'm staying in great britain for
now
but escaping from kiev i left uh half of
my
huge family
in ukraine in newcastle city
hierarchy because my family is not only
about my relatives it's also about my
close friends
all the people i was surrounded in there
all of our community
all
the bright brightest minds
young brightest minds of ukraine
they live there and my uncle
with
along with his child 11 year old
my cousin
there now in japanese region and they
constantly they can hear shelling their
house is shaking and my
my heart tears apart from hearing that
i'm honestly all of our hearts go out to
you as well and um
and your loved ones who are uh still in
ukraine of course thank you so much for
coming on the program and telling
brahim's story i feel like you've really
painted a picture of the man that he is
so we appreciate that thank you
thank you so much for listening just
spread the truth
and protect humanity protect
yeah protect humanity protect people
democracy
thank you
well that is it for this week's uh
sophie ridge on sunday broad a variety
of topics that as always they're covered
on the show with our guests in just a
moment after this short break we're
going to run through today's interviews
and have a look what we learned this
week we're going to be joined by our
island editor
david blevins to talk about the northern
ireland protocol and what people had to
say about that on the show thank you for
joining us this sunday morning
[Music]
[Music]
organization
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello and welcome to safety reach the
take where we take a moment and reflect
on what we've heard over the last hour
busy show topics range from the war in
ukraine and the government plans to send
some asylum seekers to uh rwanda but
we're having a bit of a different uh
program on the take uh this morning
because we're gonna be focusing on the
legislation that is coming tomorrow on
the northern ireland uh protocol and to
do this we are joined by somebody uh who
basically there's no one better to try
and unpick what this all uh means uh
david blevins our island correspondent a
senior ireland correspondent i should
say
who is joining us from belfast now david
before we get into the nitty-gritty of
the interviews that we did on
northern ireland i'm keen to get your
view what are you hearing on what is
actually going to happen on monday
well sophie first of all perhaps we
should just remind people what the
northern ireland protocol is because i
think that's important context it was
the compromise that boris johnson struck
with the eu to avoid the need for a hard
border between northern ireland and the
republic after brexit and they achieved
that by effectively keeping northern
ireland in the european union's single
market so there are checks on goods
coming from great britain into northern
ireland and some eu laws still apply
here now i think it's important for
people to know that because then you
understand the importance of what the
government is now proposing to do
we are hearing from very credible
sources that the bill the government
will publish tomorrow will effectively
override that northern ireland protocol
the international treaty that boris
johnson himself described as the oven
ready deal
it appears that about to tear that up
and in a significant way one senior tory
mp is describing what's on the the table
as the nuclear option because we're told
it will contain these notwithstanding
clauses in relation to the withdrawal
agreement so it really does override
what has previously been agreed and of
even more concern to many people will be
the suggestion that it removes the
opportunity for the northern ireland
assembly to have consent around all of
this
uh really uh critical uh there let's
bring in shall we some of the interviews
and come off the back of it because it
feels to me like one of the big
questions is whether or not the
government will be acting within the law
in what it is doing uh tomorrow and i
put that question to brandon lewis the
northern ireland secretary he said well
first of all he confirmed the government
is going to be bringing forward the
legislation but he was very clear
in his assurances that their proposals
would be within the law let's listen
first of all the legislation will
outline tomorrow is within the law what
we're going to do is lawful and it is
correct how can we be so sure that it
isn't going to break the law are you
going to publish the legal advice that's
based on well we're setting out the
legal basis on which we are um taking
forward this legislation i think when
people see what is the legal what is
when people see the legislation tomorrow
they will see and uh we will be setting
out our legal position on this people
will see that what we are proposing
resolves the key issues within the
protocol that don't work so what is the
legal basis on which you're publishing
this advice well we have to actually
outline what we're doing in a context
that is about protecting the integrity
of the belfast good friday group we've
always said the attorney general back in
2019 was very clear belfast's good fine
agreement absolute has paramount
importance to the uk government it's the
primacy it's the original thing it's an
international agreement between us and
the irish government are you committing
to publish publishing the advice on
which that is given well as i'm saying
first of all you'll see the latest
people will see the legislation tomorrow
they'll see that we're acting within the
law and we as a government will be
outlining our legal position and being
particularly about why this is
absolutely within the law
absolutely within the law according to
brandon lewis people will be able to see
that they are acting within the law
felt slightly frustrating trying to get
the actual nitty-gritty of any details
of the legal argument there but we are
assured it is uh coming well that's the
brandon lewis argument let's listen to
someone with a rather contrasting
perspective on whether it would be legal
on the programme we also spoke to the
president of schinfan mary lou macdonald
here's her take on brandon lewis's claim
that the legislation would be within the
law
brandon lewis is talking through his hat
and not for the first time brandon lewis
should know the tory government
should know that where there are issues
to be resolved with the protocol
issues of smoothing out its application
there are mechanisms through which that
can happen there is a willingness there
is a willingness to engage by the
european commission but the british
government has refused to engage
has not been constructive has sought a
destructive path and is now proposing to
introduce legislation that will
undoubtedly breach international law and
by the way
against the expressed democratic wishes
of people in the north of ireland who
went to the polls and who made their
democratic decision and have returned a
majority of members that support the
protocol the british parliament it seems
now is set
to have tables before us legislation
specifically designed to breach an
international agreement that that very
parliament ratified
and an agreement that not so long ago
the current occupant of number 10
downing street just described as oven
ready and let me emphasize again uh in
the democratic test on these matters at
the people of the north have spoken a
majority of mlas elected to the assembly
support the protocol and when there is a
vote in 2024 assuming that the assembly
is up and running and even if it's not a
majority of those mlas will vote to
continue and support that protocol
uh breaching international law according
to mary lou mcdonald within
international law
according to brandon lewis
david blevins can you work this out for
us and
where do we stand on whether this action
would be legal
well i think your program has shown us
this morning why there is
such growing concern in westminster
about what the government is about to
put on the table there is not just
opposition from the labour party but
from every opposition party by the
democratic unionists there's a serious
concern in brussels and in washington
about what's on the table as well
because all of this hinges really on
those not withstanding clauses that's a
very complicated term but that's what
those who were most concerned were
watching carefully for because we've had
the debate this week about the extent to
which the senior treasury council sir
james edie was asked to give his opinion
on whether or not this breached
international law he said he was not
asked to give his opinion specifically
on that issue but now that we are
hearing from a senior tory mp that this
bill will include those notwithstanding
clauses in relation to the government's
own withdrawal agreement i think it
becomes increasingly difficult for the
british government to argue that this is
not a breach of an international treaty
although until we see the legislation
published it's going to be difficult to
be absolutely certain about that sophie
yeah as you say and i was saying to you
a bit off her camera it's quite
frustrating sometimes doing these
interviews the day before things are
published because even though you or i
effectively know where things are going
it allows the ministers to say well you
just have to wait for it to be published
tomorrow you will see that it's within
the law you haven't seen the bill yet so
it gives them that effective like
blanket i suppose to to to get away from
asking the really direct questions i
guess the difficulty with legal advice
in the government is you can choose
which legal advice to take right
yes and i think um there's real
exasperation around all of that
clearly expressed by mary lou mcdonald
the shin fan president this morning
she's a tough talker at the best of
times she certainly wasn't mincing her
words this morning and that's because
most people are concerned about the fact
that this is such a complicated issue
the northern ireland protocol the
government knows that it's fairly
difficult for people to grasp the
science behind it all and therefore they
can easily be quite vague or as one
senior tory mp has said to me this
morning it's easy for them to lie to
parliament it's easy for them to lie to
the population as a whole because people
don't fully understand what is happening
and i think that explains the
exasperation the frustration we're
hearing from mary lou mcdonald and
others at this stage of this debate it's
interesting you're sort of saying about
that um a way that they're almost
misrepresenting the situation and i've
actually found it with a few politicians
here on the support or the lack of
support for the protocol among parties
in northern ireland i know something
you're always very
keen to point out that actually the
majority of people elected to the
northern ireland assembly actually are
in favor of the um protocol even if they
want some changes it happened in the
interview as well the northern secretary
brandon lewis claimed that all political
parties in northern ireland support
making changes to the protocol i was
quite keen to try and unpick that claim
when we spoke to him
in 2024 there is a cassette mechanism
and a vote for the politicians all that
and one of the things i think gets
missed sometimes is debatable i guess
all the political parties in northern
ireland at the moment are clear the
protocol is current stage doesn't work
yeah i i want to come back on that a
little bit because it's much more
complicated than that oh yeah
that does feel you know
a slight um people often talk about this
as well as one political party and
that's not actually fair all the party
leaders have been very clear both with
me in public but there's there needs to
be churches but you would accept that 54
of the 90 newly elected mlas think that
the protocol effectively should keep
going that they disagree with the idea
that it should be scrapped you can also
be changed you can also point to the
majority of uh from the parties that are
designated obviously there's a larger
proportion those are unionist mlas and
they're all the unionist party very
clear they want the protocol scrapped
all together what we're going to do is
say set out tomorrow we can restore the
institutions of northern ireland by
fixing the problems that are there with
them should you not ask if if the
principle of consent is so important you
know the exit clause you say won't be um
overruled
should you not ask the politicians in
northern ireland to get their approval
if you like for any unilateral changes
that you're willing to make when you
know uh that actually you know the
majority of people on who have been
newly elected 54 of the 90 don't want to
see it scrapped well there's also
the last wide poll on this it was done
in northern ireland a few months ago now
actually set out 78 of the population
northern ireland felt the protocol
wasn't working and needed to be fixed so
we as uk government have a
responsibility to resolve this issue for
all people in northern ireland
businesses and all the whole community
of northern which we're going to do
uh brandon lewis uh there we're also of
course uh hearing from chimpanzee leader
at moline mcdonald on the program this
morning it's quite interesting to
always contrast the two because they're
so far apart i think it does really show
the difficulty and the fragility i get
at the situation that we're talking
about she said that the government's
plans could risk power sharing in
northern ireland and even the good
friday agreement it was pretty strong
language from mary lou macdonald
just remember that when when brexit
happened and the vote was taken people
in the north voted to remain just just
remember that
and people on on a cross-community basis
from from all walks of life voted to
remain and i would wager if there was a
vote on the brexit question again next
week or next month that by an even
greater margin people in the north of
ireland would vote uh to remain so
brexit never had the democratic consent
or imprimatur of the people of the north
and therefore any idea that the tory
government would try to rob the elected
representatives of the north of ireland
of their rightful decision
on this matter would be absolutely
outrageous and and would mean that not
alone is the tory government uh
waging an onslaught against the protocol
prepared to breach international law and
walk away from its international
obligations but that in fact it is uh
damaging undermining power sharing in
the north of ireland and it would be
further and very very
very very dangerous evidence of a tory
attack on the good friday agreement uh
itself
let's bring uh david blevins back in now
shall we
both sides are using the good friday
agreement here aren't they
um
the government in the uk saying that
look the only reason we're acting is to
try and protect the good friday
agreement you had there marilyn mcdonald
saying that no this is effectively
putting the good friday agreement at
risk can you try and unpick the weeds
here and tell us what's actually going
on
yes i think the key word is consent
because mary lou mcdonald as you heard
there describes it as absolutely
outrageous and a tory attack on the good
friday agreement if the politicians in
northern ireland are not granted consent
on this
equally the principle of consent is
right at the heart of the good friday
agreement that there will be no change
to the constitutional position of
northern ireland in other words that it
will remain part of the united kingdom
until the people of northern ireland and
indeed the republic of ireland give
consent otherwise so what the unionists
are now saying is that that border in
the irish sea which is the result of the
northern ireland protocol has not been
consented to and therefore they regard
the protocol as more damaging to the
good friday agreement than brexit
arguably was to the good friday
agreement but that consent issue is
really important this morning and if we
just drill down into it for a moment
boris johnson built in his own exit
clause he gave the northern ireland
assembly the opportunity to give consent
to the protocol in 2024 and one of the
other things people have been really
waiting for to see in relation to this
legislation is if that consent is still
in place but again we understand from a
senior tory mp that the bill to be
published tomorrow will disapply the
protocol it will no longer take effect
even if the northern ireland assembly
gives it backing in 2024 and that's
being described as a nuclear option that
will really not go down well at all with
the irish government with the eu and in
america so it really does risk a trade
war with the eu and risk the possibility
of the uk not being able to secure a
trade daily with the united states just
sitting back for a minute it's i just
want to look at the situation in
westminster and how it is impacting uh
what is going on here because it feels
like look this is a week where boris
johnson faced perhaps the biggest
challenge of his premiership so far 41
of his own mps voting no confidence in
him and it seems to me that as a result
he has effectively
gone back to basics on brexit
the european research group the kind of
the most uh pro-brexit if you like uh of
group of his own mps appear to be the
guys
who have got their hand on the steering
wheel here there was talk
that the
legislation yesterday would be watered
down but if what we're hearing is
correct it actually feels like it is in
quite a tough place and then actually
the more brexiteer wing of the party
if you like in the conservative party
appear to have the upper hand
yes and it reinforces some analysis from
our deputy political editor sam coats in
the last couple of days that the
hard-line brexiteers within the tory
party are the real winners of what went
on in parliament this week because over
the last 18 months we've seen the
government stall and stall and stall on
this issue the democratic unionists have
been pleading for the government to
address their concerns about the
protocol in advance of the northern
ireland assembly election and the
government kept making promises but not
delivering the government still hadn't
delivered in order to get the democratic
unionists into the power sharing
government boris johnson appeared to be
in a place where he was attempting to
find some kind of fresh compromise with
the eu but that appears to have
dramatically changed in the course of
the last week if what we're hearing
proves to be correct tomorrow he has
moved to a much more hard-line position
the northern ireland protocol does look
like it's going to be overruled as a
result of this legislation and that
absolutely opens a minefield uh very
quickly do you think there's gonna be a
big rebellion among conservative mps
yes i would suspect there will be there
we saw significant rebellion last week
and there is growing concern
particularly around this issue of
whether or not this breaches
international law and i think it's
increasingly difficult this morning for
the government to to deny the fact that
it does
really uh interesting david thank you so
much for being on the tape this morning
giving your analysis i'm about to cough
so apologies
i was trying to hold it back until the
end of the program but i didn't make it
never mind um thank you very much for
being with us this morning that is it
from safety ridge on sunday the take i'm
gonna leave you there because i need to
get some water
[Music]
i'm ivan bonio i'm a sailor
i spent half time of my life on the on
the sea
we have a factory